Brazilian democracy and I
are almost the same age.
I thought that in our thirties,
we would both be standing on solid ground.
Petra,
the first time voting
in a historical election.
I was 19 when Lula got elected.
I remember the excitement...
Lula!
It felt like a huge step
in our democratic path.
Twenty million people leaving poverty,
unemployment reached the lowest number
in history,
and Brazil rises as a major player
on the world stage.
He's the most popular politician on Earth.
To succeed him, he chooses Dilma Rousseff,
who becomes our first female president.
We will all be judged by history.
It felt like a change of symbols.
But something in our social fabric
started to change.
Circle in!
The country divided into two parts.
And this wall...
Lock Lula up!
This is absurd!
...would rip us apart.
The party is soon caught
in a corruption scandal,
the greatest investigation
in the country's history.
What will they think of us?
My biggest regret is not having done more.
Crimes include fraud, slavery,
even homicide...
One president impeached,
another in prison...
Our democracy was crumbling.
This sexist hoax!
I get stronger each day
towards public opinion.
I fear our democracy
was nothing but a short-lived dream.